welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University visit w WC mu edu slash
multimedia
you know I should say that this place
has a very special place in my heart you
know cuz i discovered so much about
myself and so much about the world here
at carnegie mellon but i think it's
important to give back to the young
students that are here that you know i
am here largely because i wish that they
were more people like me who came back
when i was in school when I was
struggling when I didn't have the
answers when I had questions but I could
relate to and you know I believe that
you should be the change that you want
to see and Here I am you know when you
first get out sometimes you can kind of
feel like spaghetti and they just kind
of throw it at the wall till it sticks
you know and you know that's what it can
be like because you try to you know
cover all your bases you're trying to
you know sees all the opportunity that's
out there and it can be extremely
challenging and extremely frustrating
but like I said you have to realize that
auditioning is part of the process and
once you once you can forgive yourself
or forgive the world for the industry
for that you'll be all right the biggest
stumbling block to an artist's trying to
make themselves into a professional to
have a professional career it's the fact
that it they don't understand the
business that is within their art
whether it be acting or art or dance or
whatever the case is and you know you
can be a great artist but have poor
business skills and never make it and
you get out to the real one you realize
there's competition here you know
nobody's handing me anything I still
have to go and stick it and seek it and
find it Carnegie Mellon helped me to I
guess realized my full potential while I
was here I was studying acting certainly
but I was also you know taking business
classes taking writing classes the more
you know the more you're able to do as
an actor your job is to recreate you
know life truthfully experiences
truthfully
and the more experienced that you have
the better you'll be at that go boldly
into the industry and and that I guess
advice would translate to any person
coming out of the scoop go boldly
because you've earned it you know you've
earned whatever's out there you've
earned it you're prepared for it you you
hung in there and you made it so many
people are intimidated by this industry
because it is so fierce and fast and
furious but you know you should be
secure in the fact that you're prepared
and that you can handle the challenges
that will come